water
look behind the scenes of this massive
tsunami in 2012 The Impossible you'll
see that the filmmakers shot it on a
recreated set at one third the scale a
smaller set meant less water to control
even for shops that weren't filmed with
Miniatures the challenge was controlling
the unpredictable elements of a storm
while making scenes look as wild and
random as possible these tricks in the
impossible were replicated and built
upon 10 years later by the same director
and DP to engineer the perfectly chaotic
storm in the rings of power
older movies with limited equipment had
to avoid putting actors and crews in
real water environments
instead films like Ulysses and Swiss
Family Robinson shot ocean storms with
model ships in miniature tanks and when
you're destroying a miniature model that
took significant time and labor to build
you often only get one take today films
like the impossible still use scaled
down models to create ocean storms but
they found new creative ways around
those past hurdles to recreate this 2004
Indian Ocean tsunami hitting this Resort
in Thailand The Impossible built a model
of the site at one-third the scale the
smallest set that would interact with
the wave in a convincing way since
they'd have to capture the shot in one
take the Director of Photography Oscar
fowra set up a 10 camera apparatus to
catch every angle and to make sure they
got the wide ugly impact that they
wanted on the very first try the team
ran extensive wave generating tests
ultimately achieving the right level of
messiness by rushing 1 000 tons of water
over the model set with the power of
eight F1 racing cars behind it but the
key to getting convincing results was
combining Miniatures with other methods
including the most popular tool for
filming ocean storms giant water tanks
Naomi Watts and Tom Holland filmed most
of their scenes at Spain's ciudad De la
Luz Studios home to a nearly 400 foot
long Seaside tank capable of rolling out
hundreds of thousands of gallons of
water that kind of control over water is
why Hollywood most often films its ocean
storms in tanks like this one or
Pinewood Studios tank in the Dominican
Republic the site for aquatic scenes in
the lost city and old the water tank
will give you all of the control that
you need the waves will look the same
every single day the visibility will be
the same every single day everything out
in the ocean it's just a moving floating
set everything in the water tank can be
serviced from the parking lot and from
the trucks even on a windless day the
ocean never looks still so a tank needs
waves and wind to break up its
mirror-like surface which often means
wave machines this machine's plunge into
the water and just sand swells into our
set so it doesn't look like a pool for
the impossible the team modified the
design of the giant tank so that it had
33 submergible pumps which would be
hidden on camera and help move over 35
000 gallons of water through the tank
each day all of these techniques came to
the fore when building the Ultimate
Storm for the rings of Power with a team
of expert storm makers helmed by the
director cinematographer Duo from The
Impossible we went back and we tore
apart the C which is they shot we took
the film and we went through beat by
beat but for the tsunami the water came
up slowly it was more of a rise as a
giant wave whereas we were in the midst
of the sea in an overwhelming sea so the
team Drew on real world references too
we go to storm chaser material and look
and see what it actually looks like what
does the waves look like it's sea and a
giant kind of storm like this after
extensive pre-visualization the team
tested the plausibility of the shoot
with a miniature water tank then they
shot the episode in two real water tanks
the underwater portion in a smaller dive
tank and the rest in a 10 foot deep
outdoor tank capable of holding two and
a half million liters of water over the
tank the team installed a retractable
roof which allowed more control over the
lighting conditions making it easier to
extend the set in post-production but
water doesn't just absorb light it
reflects it
so rings of power swapped out the color
of the backgrounds depending on the time
of day they were depicting we had the
ability to switch it broke to Black for
night scenes to White for the fog scenes
and for Day scenes they used a blue
screen that was slightly less blue a
technique used on the impossible the VFX
team could still extract actors from it
as with a normal blue or green screen
but when it was reflected in the water
it didn't look like somebody was having
a digital blue party you know it it
looked like kind of sky for the actors
inside the tank the team built a raft we
went out into the tank with the raft and
started figuring out safety wise how can
we keep the ref Tethered to one spot so
it doesn't get pushed around in the
waves but yet still looks real the
solution was a hydraulic base like what
Dean used on 2018's adrift to show the
yacht in that movie going through a
hurricane Dean's team mounted it on a
gimbal paired with a robotic 200 ton
Digger on rings of power the underwater
gimbal attached to the steel base of the
raft it then gets soft I'll a Balsa or
Timber that goes on top which has a sock
covering so it's not going to sort of
hurt the actors at all when they're
rolling and fluffing around on it and
getting washed on and off safety was
Paramount here because of what the
actors had to stand up to
creating all those waves required a
two-pronged approach the team took cues
from earlier work in adrift which
involved two dump tank shoots mounted on
trucks each holding 4 000 liters of
water along with a big eight Cannon air
mortar for spray effects that was all
way too big for the scenario for the
wrapped because the wrap was 2.4 meters
the boat that we did was 17 meters long
so on rings of power the 4 000 liter
dump tanks became 750 liter ones and at
the bottom of the shoots the team cut
little fingers in the kicker plates to
disperse the water which helped make the
waves manageable for the smaller raft
and help to get the look they wanted so
it really more envelops in a spray than
one solid mass of water the dump tanks
provided the specifically timed waves
but for the continuous chop the team
hauled in five 14-ton construction
diggers with big steel plates mounted on
them manually operated from different
spots around the tank there's that much
resistance on the big steel plates so
that the waves that they generate would
come in and they'd peek up and put a big
broken lip on the top of them that then
catches the wind and whisks Lacrosse
waves end up coming back and rebounding
and so it makes it really nicely messy
and horrible once the waves have reached
there Optimum sort of size and then the
dump tank comes in on top the result was
convincing at least in the close-up in a
wide shot we knew that we were going to
have to extend and create CG water and
really make foreground waves that made
it even bigger and scarier but water is
famously difficult to render
realistically with CGI especially ocean
water which is constantly transitioning
between different shapes so for rings of
power the studio ilm created a digital
ocean machine that programmed the look
of CG water given a range of variables
so it was getting a system together that
would allow us to say you know how
choppy should this Earth should be how
windy is it what time of day is it
artists could even include little
details like digital streaks of froth
which better ground the waves in reality
it also helped that the waves only
became CG around six feet outside the
actors the water that actually is
touching them splashing around the raft
itself is mostly real practical
flourishes pulled the whole storm
together anything that touches the actor
anything that makes hair move or
anything like that is always best done
practically so all the rain and the wind
and everything that was hitting them so
practical and it needs to be it also
needed to be powerful for wind we have
v8 car engines mounted on purpose-built
fans eight to ten foot wide blades that
push a large volume of wind on tune it
was uh three of those being used at any
one time to make torrential pores of
rain the team could have used massive
sprinklers or rain bar structures but
instead opted for a firefighting method
pumping water through the arm of a crane
into spinning Cellar nozzles this
allowed for 360 Degree coverage and more
variable movement it's pushed out over
the filming set usually a little bit
towards the wind so that by the time it
hits the act as it's caught with the
wind and goes over the rafts all that
rain was clearly caught on camera thanks
to the controlled lighting that backlit
the water droplets and also helped the
flashes of lightning translate
powerfully on screen those were pyro
effects set off through a remote firing
system which provided a second reason
for the retractable roof when you do
lightning strikes they illuminate so
broadly that you want to make sure the
lights contained and pushed down into
the set this way we got maximal strength
from our lightning with so much done
practically on rings of power the VFX
team could focus on the details like
adding these sharp lightning bolts
painting out cameras and Equipment
reflected in the water's surface and
then seamlessly weaving together the
real and CG water
the fact that storms are chaotic by
Nature goes a long way to tying all the
effects together from waves to wind to
rain the great thing about a storm at
sea is the sea becomes very choppy and
the wind is blowing and there's lots of
stuff going on in multi-directions made
it a little bit easier of course
creating these storms only looks like
chaos so it's all a very choreographed
sort of thing to bring together it's
like a song you always have to hit the
same beats over and over